spangled donc a décidé d'ouvrir ses
magasins le dimanche en 1990 c'est la
question dimanche jour du seigneur jours
de repos ou jours de travail
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
moi je travaille à temps un play back
est des jours où ça donne pas
franchement pour ce parce que pour ceux
qui ont des enfants le ding deux jours
devant leurs parents
trente ans plus tard les questions se
pose autrement aux un sondage récemment
on a un détaillant sur la côte-nord qui
lui manque 26% de ses employés cette
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre fort sera
peut-être les détaillants affirmé
dimanche
et nous manque dans chaque magasin en
moyenne sept employés pour dire que le
magasin fonctionne de façon optimale
le manque d'employés touche sans
discrimination les provigo et iga métro
cosco oil man et les épiciers
indépendants comme ici chez pesquié
adelson émane s'est peut-être regarder
le nombre de commandes comprend enfin sa
mère
la réalité c'est effectivement on ne pas
assez de gens pour répondre aux heures
d'ouverture que des ventes du commerce
donc oui effectivement des fois vous
allez avoir des pancartes loisirs du
manque de personnel malheureusement on
doit fermer plus tôt département le
service veut pour m'agacer oui on est un
commerce de détail mais avec du service
malgré cela l'association des
détaillants en alimentation du québec
qui représente les épiciers des banners
indépendants ne recommande pas à ses
membres de fermer dimanche la loi le
permet
la grande question c'est est-ce que
l'ensemble des détaillants devraient
fermer pour l'instant moi je n'ai pas de
position au cinéma assez forts pour dire
c'est la position que nous devons
prendre même
si on doit fermer le dimanche certains
souhaitent que ce soit une mesure
imposée à tous pour éviter une
compétition déloyale il faut quoi faut
s'asseoir à la table avec quai pour
qu'il ya une décision d'ensemble on
avait beaucoup de gens je voudrais c'est
surtout les 35 je voudrais qu'il doit
regarder la question parce que c'est eux
qui ont une beaucoup plus grosse avait
pas que moi un petit indépendant c'est
là que ça devient une question de choix
personnel du marchand qui doit évaluer
le secteur privé la concurrence et faire
le choix qui est le plus pertinent pour
lui
les grandes chaînes en alimentation
représentée par le conseil canadien du
commerce de détail sont contre la
fermeture le dimanche ou tout autre
journée de la semaine
de fermer une journée n'est pas
nécessairement une solution à la pénurie
de médecins au contraire on a toujours
certaines réserves avoir une
réglementation noah mur à mur pour des
enjeux qui souvent sont locaux donc
c'était davantage de flexibilité qui
permettrait de résoudre des anges
ça peut être une solution pour certains
marchands peut-être se fait plus en
région mais c'est pas la réponse à
l'entièreté de l'enjeu surtout quand on
se trouve dans une grande surface comme
ici par exemple où il faut gérer des
inventaires maintenu manteau de produits
frais et lobait si on se retrouve une
journée où on est fermé battus cet
inventaire se trouve à ne pas vous
voulez une position que ne partage pas
une association des détaillants
indépendants
il faut diminuer les inventaires pour
éviter les pères il faut probablement
diminue aussi la production dans les
journées précédant donc il ya des choses
à faire mais je pense pas que ce soit
insurmontable la même façon qu'on
réussisse à fermer à noël où elle a donc
sonné
les détaillants l'ont d'ailleurs vécu 9
dimanche consécutif au début de la
pandémie le gouvernement legault a
décrété la fermeture des commerces
essentiel le dimanche pour donner du
repos aux travailleurs ont le vécu
pendant quelques semaines la pandémie où
on a été fermé c'est que ça met
énormément de pression sur les équipes
les six autres jours où on est rouvert
qui doivent partout même travail un
séjour les consommateurs sont aussi
divisés sur cette question mais la
clientèle denis paquette semble prête à
changer ses habitudes
on avait posé la question justement
autant ducobu quand on a fermé les
violences est-ce que les gens justement
pas conservé et les commerces fermés
dimanche puis c'était très positif on
dirait notre clientèle note magasins
avaient fermé plus tôt aujourd'hui où
sera fermée pour permettre aux gens de
profiter avec leurs familles et les gens
nous félicitent et même si tous les
acteurs de l'industrie alimentaire ne
s'entendent pas sur la réduction des
offres d'affaires tous s'accordent à
dire qu'il faut trouver une façon pour
pallier la pénurie de travailleurs faut
adresser les vrais problèmes l'homme est
il vrai problème la main d'oeuvre on
vient aux enjeux d'automatisation
on peut penser aux caisses automatiques
à l'étiquetage de méricourt aux
inventaires en temps réel pour vraiment
faire en sorte que les ressources
humaines soient concentrés ou une plus
value réelle pour le consommateur on
entend beaucoup de gens nous rapporter
des problèmes pour trouver des employés
à temps plein en semaine c'est là qu'on
constate mais c'est pas seulement une
question de rails tout une question
d'organisation du travail de revoir
certains processus à l'intérieur de nos
magasins pour pouvoir attirer des gens à
différentes heures de façon un peu
différente
les sections emplois de tous les
détaillants affiche une multitude de
postes chez pasquier une vidéo passent
en boucle à l'entrée de l'épicerie pour
faire du recrutement de personnel
certains suggèrent l'augmentation des
salaires mais la proposition ne fait pas
l'unanimité
minimum à 15 dollars c'est sûr qu'on
regarde aussi ce qui se fait dans les
autres provinces un propriétaire
d'épicerie misère que si le salaire
minimum augmente ex était fatale pour
lui est ce que c'est une réalité pour
certains commerçants savent rien de
venir sinon l'autre option cessé
d'augmenter les prix dont
l'élasticité que peut se permettre le
consommateur il faut vraiment
s'interroger là dessus avant d'aller
jusque là
tombé
[Musique]